hey what's up guys and welcome back to
Rob's world I hope you like the new
introduction as much as I do big thanks
to cyber toons for making that for me on
my last video actually got some requests
for a paper wallet so I actually
designed my own and I posted it on
Facebook where it got just about 100
likes and 50 comments so thank you very
much for all your feedback you just need
one sheet of printer paper to make it
but if you want to make it with two
colors like this one then you're gonna
need two sheets so grab your paper and
let's get started so you can avoid
situations like this hey how you doing
hey you don't please just this that's
five dollars please
five dollars okay there you go I think
you could use a wallet yeah I guess I
could use a wallet here's an easy one
that I made out of paper one second this
is mine hey that's pretty cool how do
you do that sure I can show you how to
make it so this is my paper wallet
design as you'll see it has two pockets
one here that you can put money in and
one here which you could put two cards
in it's made with one single sheet of
eight-and-a-half by 11 letter sized
paper however if you want to make it
more durable and thicker and also give
it two colors then you can make it with
two sheets what you would do is just
take one sheet and put another sheet
right on top of it and that way this
bottom color will be the color that's on
top I would recommend first trying it
with a single sheet though once you have
the paper like this you can take the top
end and fold it down to the bottom end
line up the edges and then make a crease
along the top and run your fingernail
just to make that edge sharp unfold the
paper
and now you have this line which divides
the paper in half we're going to take
the top edge and the bottom edge and
fold it directly on to the line just
like that once it's lined up and you can
make a crease along the top do the same
for the bottom and we're going to take
the bottom edge here and we're going to
fold it down just like this except
you're not going to fold it down so that
it meets that bottom edge you're
actually going to fold it past the
bottom edge something like that okay and
the easiest way to do this is basically
flip the paper over pull down on this
edge like this until that pops out then
you can take this folded edge and just
kind of take your finger and pull the
edge in like that until you have a
little bit of overhang you can actually
take it and pull it out if you need a
little more but right when it's about
there then you make a crease right here
on the paper the paper was folded down a
little bit past that bottom folded edge
then what we're going to do is we're
going to take the excess now and I'm
going to fold it right down along this
edge to lock this bottom pocket so just
fold it down all the way across like
that
and make a good crease with your
fingernail all the way across okay so
now if you flip the paper back over
you'll see we now have a little bottom
pocket here now you can unfold the top
edge and right on this crease which is
actually a valley-fold so right along
this crease just fold that edge back and
then give it a good crease now you can
take this folded edge and we're going to
take it and put it down right in this
pocket okay right in here like that then
you have this free edge we're actually
going to fold this free edge down so
that it's right about here just a little
down past the top of this pocket take
the edge and fold it down right about
there and give it a good crease all the
way across now you can actually lift up
this bottom edge pull the pocket back
fold it and then let the bottom pocket
again be on top here make sure
everything is nice and flat we're
actually going to fold these edges in
just the teeny bit maybe the width of
your pinky
fold the left side in just like that and
make a good crease on the edge then you
can unfold it and fold this top corner
in so that the top edge here is aligned
on that vertical line just like that
like an airplane just give it a good
crease now you can unfold this bottom
pocket and then once again take this
edge and fold it in just like that right
when you get to the the end here just
push that down and then you could take
this edge here like this and pinch it
then once again take this bottom folded
edge for the bottom pocket and fold it
up like that now what you could do is
turn the wallet over and you're going to
take this corner and just fold it in
again like an airplane then you could
take this whole tab and fold it back on
the back of the wallet and just give it
a good pinch and you might want to just
take it and just round it up a little
bit like that then you could once again
fold it over and you finish the left
side do the same with the right side
fold the edge in just a little bit and
make a crease unfold it tuck the top
corner in take the bottom pocket and
pull it out once again fold that right
side in push down all the way and tuck
this in here and give it a good pinch
then once again take this top this edge
push it
flip the wallet over this corner goes in
and then this whole tab gets folded just
like that and then you could pinch it
here and just give it a little bit of a
rounding off like that okay so now all
you need to do is to put your thumb in
the middle and push it like that just
round it off like that if the edge fold
it across to the other edge squeeze it
right here and just give it a good pinch
here and crease it all the way along the
edge of the wallet here and there you go
you have a paper wallet big pockets for
cash and the little pocket for cards
thank you guys for watching our tutorial
for the paper wallet I hope you like my
design
one thing that you could do if it kind
of bothers you these tabs you can
actually apply a teeny bit of tape right
here and right here and it should hold
together pretty well and be stable what
do you think Leah do you like my wallet
if you did enjoy it please give it a
thumbs up down below you can also
subscribe to my videos by clicking this
little link down here I've gotten a lot
of requests for a triple in your star
and I came up with something like this
and it's really not that good it's kind
of flimsy but I do know someone who has
a better one I'm thinking about making a
tutorial so leave me a comment below if
you guys want to see a tutorial for the
triple ninja star I'll see you next time
you look
we think of this
you